good evening everybody and uh warm
welcome to the academy of motion picture
arts and sciences
i'm john blum one of the three governors
in short films and feature animation
branch
thank you
you're too kind
those of you who've been here before
should know better than to encourage me
like that you know
the other governors in the branch are
john lasseter and bill croyer and uh i'm
and i
will join you
and uh i'm i'm also serving as the chair
of the branch this year of course
tonight we're here to screen the
nominated
live action and animated shorts
and to meet the filmmakers it's an
annual event and
very excited to be here in fact this is
my 11th year
that i've been privileged to welcome you
and in that time i have talked
frequently about my hopes for getting
these nominated shorts to a wide
audience and every year it does get
wider
much wider in addition to today's
release on itunes in 56 countries around
the world and a nationwide cable
pay-per-view release
by video on demand we're also
now in 138 theaters in major markets for
the theatrical release across the
country and that theatrical release
continues to explode
two years ago for the first time we
passed the one million dollar threshold
at the box office
last year
the release theatrically grossed a
million 350.
and this year
we have crossed the million dollar mark
in only the first 11 days of the release
to have grossed it's terrific
to have grossed through yesterday a
million sixty thousand
so we truly are making the shorts
available to a wider audience an
audience that is receptive and growing
in fact we are enjoying better than 30
percent annual growth in the theatrical
release year after year after year
we're projecting this year's box office
tally to be over a million seven hundred
thousand
that's a very respectable
number for a small independent release
and by the way bigger
than half of the foreign and documentary
feature nominee
releases i'm also pleased to announce
this year after a couple of year break a
dvd of the nominees collection will
again be released
pretty good overall
i want to give a quick shout out to
ellen harrington and her staff every
year they do a marvelous job i should
thank them this way every year but i
haven't and i just want to make a point
of it and and thank them for putting on
this wonderful night
and speaking of the great job that ellen
does we have been fortunate to have some
wonderful hosts for this event and
tonight is no exception
it's interesting we have seen of late
many high-profile live-action directors
trying their hand at animated features
directors like spielberg zemeckis tim
burton gore verbinski to name but a few
our host tonight has reversed that
course
going from a highly successful directing
career at pixar that included two oscars
for the incredibles and rat tattooey to
say nothing of an earlier annie award
for iron giant
he's even made some animated shorts now
he has made the move from animation to
live action directing with his debut
feature
a small project
you guys know what i'm going to say with
tom cruise that you may have heard of
mission impossible ghost protocol
having grossed over
today having grossed over 200 million
dollars at the u.s box office and
praised as reinventing the mission
impossible franchise
we think he is uniquely qualified to
emcee this evening's filmmaker q and a's
with a sterling resume in both animation
and live action
i'm very proud to welcome our host for
this evening the very talented brad bird
thank you
uh it's great honor to be here tonight
um
uh you know to me the whole um
thing about oscars is they're
celebrating the medium that i love and
and uh as a lover of film both animation
and live action um
it's it's a real pleasure for me to kind
of host a an evening that celebrates
both
and as a long time oscar watcher i've
had to
endure the yearly uh
dissection of what's wrong with the
oscars you know which is you know it's
part of the normal rotation of things
you know and uh
it always seems to stem from looking at
the oscars as a tv show and not as a
celebration of film which is what it is
um you know and and there's all these
you know lame-ass suggestions like you
should cut the sound oscars the makeup
the cinematography the shorts everything
but the actors and the best picture
basically
and um
but to those of us who
love the medium you know the craft the
art of
film we can't imagine not celebrating
every key part of the process
and uh we love all that goes into
sitting in the dark with strangers and
watching a handcrafted dream on a giant
screen
and tonight we're here to celebrate
short films and
you know if if
feature films are sort of you know
products of a night's worth of dreaming
these are like products of power naps
you know and uh they're vivid and uh
they're uh to the point and it's hard to
be
simple and it's hard to be brief and um
these films uh i think
um force you into a position where you
have to you know be concise and and
that's a a hugely important thing no
matter you know what length of film it
is
um so it's it's hard to be brief and it
is also rewarding so uh without any
further waiting let's look at the
oscar-nominated films and uh which will
be followed by a short panel discussion
with the filmmakers and we're starting
with animation
the fantastic flying books of morris
lessmore william joyce brandon oldenburg
directors
hmm
okay
time
oh
so
hmm
dear mother and father
happy news
i have secured for myself 90 acres of
prime ranch land which to my delight
has upon is an absolutely wizard ranch
house
i'm writing this letter from my veranda
and i'm very pleased with my situation
i believe i may now call myself
a rancher oh give me a ranch in a big
pair of pants and give me a stetson two
and let me
englishmen
end up out here with a whole lot of
dollars
no sense
they're wonderful dancers but i
certainly wouldn't marry one of them
they put a sign in the window no credit
extended to englishman it's our policy
they never pay their bills give me the
white open spaces
i'm just like a prairie flower growing
wilder every hour oh give me a moon the
prairie moon and give me a gallow
cersei lutecum
the common swamp thistle
tell me oh chap
when a swallow snaps up a gnat
do you think god decided that that
particular swallow should snap up that
particular gnat at that particular
instant
no no
it's natural selection i tell you
survival of the fittest
no
he's not a religious man
i fear he comes to church
not to nourish his soul but
with the hopes of securing a nice lunch
after the service
so let's uh welcome up all the nominees
come on up
you all have name cards there
so congratulations all of you
thank you
thank you
are we missing someone
sue
sue
here she comes here ladies and gentlemen
let's give it up for sue
she did that on purpose waiting for the
grand entrance
okay
um so
uh
you each chose a very different
techniques and and graphic styles
can we just get a brief thing from each
of you on why you picked the style that
you picked because there's everything
under the sun represented there you
start with you bill
you know we
gosh
less more morris less more yeah
um
it was a story about hurricane katrina
it was our story about how much we love
books it was a story about how we think
stories can
redeem you and and save you
and
in the aftermath of katrina
the whole city of new orleans was sort
of gray and it lost its color
and we found drifts of books
washed around in the detriest of the
storm
and
so the first thing was like
it felt like
i found myself thinking about the wizard
of oz and how it had gone from sepia to
color
and
so we thought well buster keaton too and
well things that made us happy you know
we
we turned up to the storm to things that
made us happy so
in writing the story
you know we
brandon and i looked each other like you
know there's an opportunity here to use
almost every kind of animation that we
love
without just being fetishist about it i
mean it may actually help the story
and so
we thought about doing 2d for humpty
because he was on the printed page
and he didn't need to be a 3d character
we wanted to do um
miniatures for the sets because there's
something about
seeing all the destruction
that we wanted to sort of feel it in our
hands and build it and we loved the old
fleischer cartoons and the way they had
done that so we hoped that if we you
know mixed
miniatures with with computer animation
and and everything else that we loved
like that that it would it would congeal
nicely as brandon often says it would
make a nice gumbo yeah good so uh do you
have anything to add to that uh all i
was gonna say is with the the three
blocks of the french quarter that we
built happy fat tuesday everyone yeah
that um today's mardi gras we we at the
time uh didn't have um a lot of money to
throw at this and or or people so we we
wanted to get our hands dirty and we
wanted to do the things that we loved
about what we've observed people who do
live action and they are able to get
their hands there they're able to get
out and walk around and do things
instead of sit down at a table or at a
computer and so that was invigorating to
us is to think about how we could get
out there get our hands dirty and make
things with our hands and on top of that
it was it was we didn't have a crew at
the time it was just a few of us
and and so we thought well we could you
know let's go back to our roots let's go
back to being kids making these you know
forts and doll houses and things and
just you know put all this together and
the one thing is computers do things so
perfectly so cleanly that you're
constantly battling it to make it
imperfect and to make it right dirty and
feel the hand of the creator and the
object that's being shown to you and so
that was the quickest way to do it is
actually make it with our hands
excellent um what about uh a morning
stroll grant and sue what what what
would you say
about the reason for the style i suppose
was uh
we kind of had this story that we wanted
to relay
we had a structure that dictated that
every chapter had to be 50 years on from
one another so those visuals reflected
the times they were setting so 1959 had
to be kind of black and white
you know reasonably straightforward
clean cut 2009 should feel really larry
and colorful and over bright and lots of
visual noise and almost a kind of
virtual life avatar type feel to it and
then 2059 just as tangible and as real
as we could make it and i think we like
that idea of
the story becoming
this we kind of open up with it's um
fictitious new york times kind of
uh journal and it's kind of
proposing that there's some kind of
intellectual weight to the film when
there's not and that becomes more and
more unsophisticated the visuals on the
other hand become more and more
sophisticated and that kind of idea yes
interested us so that was the reasons
for that zombie apocalypses tend to be
less sophisticated don't you think
we went the other way yeah
um and rico
yeah um well i i pitched the idea with
with watercolors i you know that's
usually how i kind of write visually and
it was pencils and watercolors and that
you know i i completely agree with brad
that that made me want to kind of fight
the slight coldness that can
imperfection that the computer has
and that way so we we scanned as many
textures that we could possibly you know
so it's pastels
um it's for for our background so our
backgrounds are actual scan pastels we
didn't really do much with it right uh
so we try and bring as much of the
actual media you know again we had shade
shading people that normally would do
everything in photoshop we're like no no
we want you to just get the you know
brushes out and we're gonna you know
watercolor every plank of this boat and
then kind of put it on it so we were
trying to get that tactile feel right
and that again in service a story that
feels like a fable and wanted to be a
fable so that that
it won't it seemed like it fit an
english and more illustrative
style
right what about you patrick um
demonstrates sunday yeah um i i chose a
drawing on paper because they this is a
only way i know to animate i don't know
how to animate by computer or by puppet
so it was a natural choice to do it like
like that um yeah right and wildlife
amanda and wendy um we uh when we
finished our film uh when the day breaks
in 1999 we thought okay
we're going into computers with this you
know this handmade stuff is just for the
birds it takes too long and
so we tried um
no pun intended um
the we tried to to come up with a
computer technique that we thought
suited the story
and we were unable to find anything that
kind of had the depth that we really
yearn for so we started working with
real paint and
we felt it suited the idea as a
you know we started out as our original
uh inspiration was kind of folk painting
you know the the kinds of things you see
on old boxes so we wanted that kind of a
palette and that kind of a feel
and it you know it's just what brandon
was saying that um
we just wanted you know paint brings you
mistakes and accidents and and
randomness that uh we were really
missing so that's how we ended up going
back to
painting right i get the impression
there's not a lot going on in canada is
that
the last three there's like a lot of
train tracks and waiting and
there's some lively bars
you guys have time to animate yeah
yeah so um
you got you two met in film school or at
school but you did separate films right
and then then
when and why did you decide it would be
a better idea to collaborate
um well after art school i went off to
montreal actually i was a couple years
ahead of amanda in art school so i went
off to montreal
to make a film and
amanda stayed in vancouver which is
where we
were at art school and made a film and i
started when the day breaks
i can't remember what year but i was
struggling with it and i felt like i
could really
use a collaborator and amanda and i had
always been very sympathetic in our
sensibilities or sense of humor or
aesthetic
so i said why don't you come to montreal
and
jump into the trench with me
so she did and we made that film
together and
have been working together ever since
and it's a great collaboration we really
enjoy it and um you two are the other
collaborators in terms of directing
and uh when did you guys decide uh that
would be a good way to go well i had
been working at pixar
and brandon had seen my children's books
and
the stuff i'd done in toy story
and i lived in shreveport louisiana he
lived in dallas and was working yeah
it's like two hours
and he was like i got this call one day
like uh like are you like william joyce
like the children's author guy
and i was like
you know sometimes i just story you'll
get to do an impression too
i believe in equal time impressions yeah
that's good too
and uh and for once i went now this
sounds
at least weird enough to be interesting
so i said yes
and
he said you know we have this like you
know animation company and we really
like to like work with y'all and be
really cool and uh could you like come
over and like work with us or something
and so that's a wiggle room legally you
know so i went yeah
like we'll sign anything you want and
you know whatever
so i said you know told my wife i'm
driving to dallas again she's like what
you have too much to do i'm like i don't
know something
i just got a sense for this right so i
get there and
their children
i mean this guy i don't know he did some
dorian gray thing i don't know he's he's
like
38 or something i don't even know how
old he is but this was
12 years ago and he i pull up he didn't
even know how to tell me how to get
there i mean it was like he didn't have
no directions like
i was like i think we're we're sort of
next to the hooters downtown
that's true yeah
and we just hit it off i'm like well you
know he's a kid no one here shaves their
moms give them to rides to work and
you know this is some youth outreach
program i don't know
and but
it
like we totally dug the same stuff and
we cracked each other up and
we just started working on things
together and so
when i started moonbot the first person
i hired was brandon and
yeah that that project is is connected
to i mean it had a weird it's
it's a ipad
app i just sort of found this out right
i mean it's something that that
interfaces with something else that's
even bigger and more complicated now he
can do the imitation
we were um just finishing up shooting
the
the miniatures
when the announcement came from apple
about the ipad
and
it was like this thing
that we had always dreamt of but didn't
even know about
it yeah
it was like that
we wanted to touch the screen
yeah so
so
yeah
we must we must do something with this
so um
we weren't expecting to make any money
off of the short and but we were like
maybe we could make some money if we
repurpose these assets make an app but i
have no idea adam and we don't have know
how to make an app so we just found out
the word app
so
anyway so we we immediately just tried
to figure out how we could do this and
so we made
an app out of the existing assets that
were created for the short film wow yeah
i really am interested in that um no i
mean it's it's it's i think these things
are cross feeding each other it's in a
really interesting way and and
that sort of ties into the zombie
apocalypse don't you think it does
doesn't it yes yeah um so when how did
the multi-time period guy watch this
chicken idea come about
and do you know
there's a part two to this question do
you know something about a coming zombie
apocalypse that we don't
i want that app as well
um i forgot the first question i'm
really sorry um the multi-time period
guy watches chicken oh yeah that came
from there's a really short short short
story about four lines in a true tales
of american life book about a woman who
sees a chick and walk down the street
and wrap on the door and get gets let in
is that the story is interesting yeah
we're celebrating shorts tonight by the
way don't make it seem so inadequate you
know
that's the story don't worry
and it's all the questions around that
like who who trains the chicken to go
for a walk in a city and where's the
chicken going
you know stretching its legs it just
all these kind of questions were really
odd and got me thinking about it but
then got me thinking about in a visual
way and how maybe how you could tell
that story and where it would lead to
you are such an animator
and i say this as an animator yes it's
the kind of things that you keep you up
at two in the morning
who got the chicken to knock
white nudging me to go to sleep zombies
be involved yes exactly
yeah um so you you built it from that
premise and and yeah i mean certain
projects that you just you kind of
try to apply rules to so
i think we mentioned this before it
stops you repeating yourself so the rule
wasn't a visual rule it was a kind of
structural rule that each chapter had to
be have the the same shot construction
and the length and composition and then
it would be all about the subtle
differences between the time periods
right and you know i mean
we never thought of a as a zombie film
to begin with i mean it's not a genre or
subgenre that i'm kind of that familiar
with but when after 100 years the
chicken is still roaming the street i
mean we thought he's the ultimate
survivor yeah and what in a hundred
years time what is the most challenging
environment for him to exist in right
and so therefore
urban apocalypse yeah
yeah naturally but it's not my or sue's
personal view oh we don't think we're
going down that road
but you are making a zombie app right
please
yeah that yeah
that did look like fun actually
yeah careful because enrico's ready to
copyright it tonight so you better beat
him to it
i would check out the exit yeah
um so enrico you had the uh very
bizarre and unique experience of having
um a large studio
that is interested in making short
projects and will support people making
them so
uh it's kind of like its own
you know one building national film
board of canada i mean once a year
um yeah
what was that uh you know uh what was it
like knowing that you know it has a good
chance to be
uh you know seen and and and yet it's
it's got its own uh disciplines
yeah i found it really interesting i
mean the first thing that hit me is just
the the honor and the responsibility of
this idea you're gonna have your story
you're you're moving
same by
you know thousands and millions of of
kids and people so
i made me think about kids right away
for some reason maybe you know i have a
i had a two-year-old daughter at the
time and i was like i felt the
responsibility to want to give a good
message something something positive
so that that's the first thing because
that's what you get with the pixar short
it goes in front of a feature and
there's a lot of people around the world
seeing it and i know we you know uh i
think the idea is that you want to
encourage other people to do the same
thing
but you know there's always got to be
the explanation of how you're going to
return and that's why it's so cool that
digital distribution is allowing more
and more of these films to be seen by a
wider and wider audience because it's
its own
um uh wonderful you know medium you know
your film uh dimash sunday uh
it sort of focuses on
two important uh elements sort of
boredom and death and uh um can you talk
about the relationships of the animals
to the child's boredom
yeah um i try to construct the the story
in two level
level one where the the boy is uh is
trying to escape is boredom by his
imagination and this the second point i
tried
uh
in the film it's to make a portrait of a
remote region
of of canada it's not an optimistic
portrait because everything is dying the
the factories is closed and even the
fruit of the
imagination of the boy is dying and the
art of conversation too
i remember
speaking very similarly too yeah yeah
yeah
they would understand each other
and the crew that are never very far so
yeah i tried to make a little portrait
of my region yeah well it was it's it's
a wonderful uh challenge and
contradictory because you're trying to
make an interesting film about boredom
you know and it is it's wonderful it
reminded me of when i was a kid looking
at adults i just remember the forest of
legs and and it just seemed like
ruthless
but it was like jesus you know get on
with it guys you know um so yeah
everyone i i think as liv this kind of
journey as a kid you you follow your
parents and you don't want to be there
right
exactly
um so you three um all worked with the
national film board of canada um you
know we're we're there there's a lot of
filmmakers here who are envious of that
kind of system what makes it so
successful and do you guys want to start
first and then go back to you
um
public funding
no but i mean public funding doesn't
ensure results no but it it increases
the odds i think i mean that's my
opinion but um i think that the national
film board is one of the few
bodies left in the world
where filmmakers can can actually
get funding for ideas of their own
and of their own design of their
own making and have the time and the
resources to actually
uh do it without the the constraint of
um a commercial audience or um
a commercial market and it's not that
you know the film board doesn't want
them to be successful or to be seen or
to be
even purchased but um the motive is
different
and i think it um
it allows for a certain kind of
experimentation which we've a lot of
people have done over the years at the
nfb a lot of techniques have been
developed a lot of uh a lot of great
stuff has come out of there and i think
that's why
it's also the culture you know that it
started out with norman mclaren and the
kind of wild stuff he was doing in the
40s and 50s and he set the bar and then
i think everybody who comes to the film
board comes you know in a high state of
worship and feeling like they've got to
do them proud so that's a big part of it
as well
and and do you have anything to add to
that yeah
it's um
it's the director point of view at the
nfb and
um we listen to comments but at the i
finally it's the director who decide
which film he wants to make oh sounds
like film heaven well i would love to uh
talk to you guys all night but there are
more films to see and so well done um
good luck on sunday we're gonna